all those years ago um i mean when you
were 19 i think you're at summer league
and you tweeted something about i'm not
leaving milwaukee until i win a
championship
uh that is i'm out now can i leave now
that's i mean that's your call i want to
trade
who i got to talk to for the trade john
just thinking of that 19 year old kid
like that's
i mean that's a statement i don't even
know if you like understood it at that
point i didn't understood it
no i wouldn't make it i would have made
that statement but that's that's what i
believe
i believe and um you know like how kids
little kids
are very honest you know you act like a
kid like
a five-year-old kid am i getting some
pounds and
he's gonna respond to yeah you're fat
like they're brutally honest and
that was me at that point like i was so
honest you know after the
the summer league and we played four
games five games
please wait out baby
we've played four games five games and
we like lost all of them
you know and i was like okay
i want to win a championship and walk in
uh i'm gonna do whatever it takes
in order for for me to win it and uh we
did it
we did it man